Joe Biden getting blasted for refusing
to stand up to the left's woke nonsense
Bill Maher thinks it's time for the
president to grow a spine
one of the things I hate the most about
Biden is that he never stands up to woke
nonsense in his party he also doesn't
want to fight that wing of his party he
knows that's where a lot of the energy
is in the party and here's the type of
thing that Mars talking about
[Applause]
star swimmer Riley Gaines says she and
others got attacked by unhinged leftists
who were Hawking loogies and throwing
bottles it happened while they were
attending the signing of Texas governor
Greg Abbott's save women's sports act
which pumps the brakes on transgender
athletes the Rabid radicals even going
after children
we were told that it wasn't safe outside
because they were completely unhinged to
be honest as we could see as they were
spitting on people they were calling
fifth graders and third graders
transphobes it was absolutely ridiculous
but here's one celebrity willing to
stand up to the woke mob singer Neo in
hot water after speaking out against
children changing their gender
I feel like parents have almost almost
forgotten what the role of a parent is
amen if your little boy comes to you and
says Daddy I want to be a girl
and you just let him rock with that when
did it become a good idea to let a
five-year-old let a six-year-old let a
12 year old make a life-changing
decision for theyself Neo initially
posting a written apology to his social
media but now he's reversing course
deleting the post and saying it came
from his publicist computer check this
out
if my opinion offended somebody yeah
sure I apologize for you being offended
because that wasn't my intention my
intention is never to offend anybody
however I'm entitled to feel how I feel
I'm absolutely entitled to feel how I
feel the same way you are entitled to
feel how you feel
all right Dana Perino yes all right so
you don't see that often you don't see a
celebrity apologize and then take it
back
well I think in this instance in
particular it was the publicist that got
ahead of him and apologized on his
behalf like they know better than he
does and I would just say like if you
you're a publicist and not the artist
for a reason yeah now you could give
advice and maybe that they're not going
to take it then your job is to help them
defend themselves so thankfully for him
he's got the power to directly talk to
his fans so that he can say no actually
that I didn't say that and I would say
that the publicists need to trust your
artist look at Jason Aldean so I I can I
just assure you oh yeah
at the PR department at the label
they're like what are we going to do
what are we going to do and they
probably wrote an apology for him to put
out but he's big enough and strong
enough and
uh convicted enough to say no you're not
going to do that to me and why would you
trust your artist look what happened
do you think that company is happy that
their song is number one now people that
work within the building might feel
uncomfortable they might be I have but
it's not that's not you're not the
artist they are and so that that was one
thing that I thought on this and then
for what Mars said about Joe Biden I
mean
it comes from the top but you look at
the cabinet you could just go around and
see like Michael Cardona at the
Secretary of Education he put critical
race Theory books into the federal
education guidance that started there
you look at mayor Pete what was some of
the first things that happened if there
is a train derailment it has to be
racism it doesn't actually have to be
like oh actually there was a problem
here if you look at the guy Sam Britton
who worked at the energy Department I
mean so he's choosing the people that
are seating the government now he will
say I'm moderate Joe I'm a but that is
just not how people have seen it in
practice and the left is going to be
shocked when they get the election
results and say wow oh people are really
concerned about this transgender issue
and children they think that they're
going to have to then go out and send
other reporters to go into the country
and do all these investigative reports
about wow what do people really think
and Joe Biden has never directly
answered whether he thinks men should
compete against women well I mean you
have to go back to what Dana said this
the administration is the political
version of the bar in the first Star
Wars it's crazy I mean Rachel Levine I
put I would add that that person uh this
is not an unhealthy group of people this
is an unhealthy group of people I think
Bill Maher is waking up to the woke and
also my ratings uh but if he shouldn't
expect Joe fighting to stand up to the
woke because he can hardly stand up as
it is Neo however pulled back the
curtain and he shows you how most
celebrities opinions are not their own
uh and they're they're usually pressured
into a form of Conformity that keeps
them out of trouble with activists
generally publicists are liberal female
bitter cat owners who hate the world and
by the way I'm not including Fox PR in
this they are an amazing group of people
because they have to fight the whole
world that hates Fox they own dogs they
own dogs and guns but generally I mean I
worked in magazines and the publicists
that were there were extremely bitter
unhappy leftists and I think what we're
what we're coming to now and and also
just to point out uh black men in
general are more conservative than they
than than they are appeared to be on
television and it's always refreshing to
be reminded that people don't think as
groups they think as individuals we're
coming to the realization you can't just
make up a protected class out of thin
air and then punish people for refusing
to comply to that new protected class
that is textbook fascism right you
create a boundary and punish those who
won't stay within them this is the most
aggressive intolerant faction I've ever
seen and that's trans activism it's a
tiny minority it doesn't speak for all
trans but within it is a mix of delusion
the subtle threat of violence and hate
it is fascism to a t in this case that t
stands for Trans but again it's only a
small group of people but they're
scaring the crap out of out of uh
publicist who in a sense are easy
pickings spitting on someone I remember
during the pandemic that was considered
assault yeah now they're just doing it
Hawking loogies All Over Texas well with
that crowd you might have something
worse to be worried uh then covet coming
out of those mouths pretty disgusting
um with Neo he says if you're offended
okay well what is so offensive about
what he said he's basically saying I
don't want drugs that are used to
castrate sexual predators in federal
prison to be given to Children which
then start their growth and make it so
they cannot have children I also don't
want adults behind my back whether
they're people at school or adults that
they're not familiar with giving those
drugs to my children and I don't want
kids to be taken away from their parents
if they tell their five-year-old that
they are not a girl if they're actually
a boy and vice versa when it comes to
Joe Biden you know I don't know if he's
directly said he doesn't want men in
women's sports or men in women's locker
rooms but his administration policies
have spoken very loudly I mean they've
sent out entire memos pushing sex change
operations for children through Medicaid
you have the Department of Education
saying that they were going to withhold
lunch money from schools if they did not
allow men to heat in women's sports in
K-12 education I mean their policies
speak for themselves when it comes to
this issue and the last thing is well
they say why are no Democrats standing
up against this there was a bill in
April that was put on the house floor to
protect women's sports by only allowing
women to compete and 203 Democrats voted
against it wow that's a lot of Democrats
you know what if you're trying to
bolster Title IX and Democrats vote
completely against it on behalf of women
and it's not just about competition and
stealing records it's about not being in
the locker room with a man which is used
to be considered sexual predator
behavior and now they're trying to
normalize it are Democrats blind to this
issue if Republicans exploit this in the
next election 200 Democrats voting for
men competing against women
we can point to a lot of votes but I
will tell you I think you're right
you're on to something I think we are we
live at a time where if you disagree
with someone uh instead of having a
debate about it or having a discussion
people want to just cancel them if they
don't like the view they find the view
so obnoxious I happen to think that
um this issue of men who transition to
being a woman competing in sports
against women I've shared with a young
daughter I'm I'm I'm not settled on this
I'm not been persuaded this is the
right thing to do for some of the
reasons you articulated Katie and others
around the table uh have to be the
subject and a target of Bill Maher uh is
really kind of a treat he has he has
been someone who's really not spared
anyone and has talked about this issue a
whole lot and I find a lot of what he
says uh interesting uh Joe Biden I would
disagree a little bit kid I think we can
put him in the same category with
everybody Administration the policies or
what the policies are but he is not he's
not but he's not spoken on this he
hasn't been asked him oh no the other
side the Republicans who were talking
about the cultural and the the wokeness
are not doing well in the primaries
either DeSantis who probably has been
the greatest champion some of the
polling data suggest that this is not
where people want the conversation to be
that doesn't mean they don't agree with
us on some of the issues that we're
talking about but I think people are
more interested in some of the bigger
more important issues but when you when
you when you pigeonhole someone like you
did this young star Neo the rapper the
singer I like his music
um you see that people want to share
their own views and if you want to
debate him on this you debate him one
issue but don't cancel them whether
you're democrat or republican you
disagree with someone debate them let's
get a a contest of ideas as opposed to
You're So I disagree with you so much I
want to cancel you and don't want to
hear your voice that's not what politics
and that's not what America is about
wait a second it's Neo or Neo
I mean in my house we call them Neo I
don't know I just said Neo I knew who
you were talking about though I don't
know what I'm talking I'm not going to
cancel I have no idea I think we all
learned something and that is that
publicists are bitter cat
publicists are despicable creatures
whoever forced him to apply did that
apology we should find out who that is
yeah and then what should we do I don't
know right a Stern letter to her parents
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis